welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one hidden undercurrent
linking all of marvel studios phase four
storylines
from imminent ones like one division in
the falcon winter soldier
to ones more on the horizon like the
nick fury series and miss marvel
is the way each of these titles will do
its part to establish the new avengers
now i've been talking about this just a
bit with characters like those twins in
one division most likely being wiccan
billy kaplan in speed tommy shepard
based on the west coast avengers comics
i'm pretty sure it's partly adapting
the fridge art in the shape of a bee for
billy and another shape we're all
pretending is a
tea for tommy but most strikingly a hint
of a red
glow on the fingertips of one of those
babies perhaps
wiccan inheriting his mama's red chaos
magic
and these are the other kids we've been
talking about cassie lange returning in
ant-man 3 as stature
hawkeye's protege kate bishop appearing
in hawkeye and we're starting to see
a young avengers lineup coming together
in the mcu but there is one other
newcomer that i think we overlooked
but one who might have just confirmed
exactly how marvel face 4 will introduce
these characters
i am talking about kamala khan with iman
valani recently announced to play the
teenage superhero in the upcoming marvel
disney plus series
miss marvel maybe coming as soon as next
year believe it or not we might have
gotten our hands on one of the most
revelatory inside scoops on this series
honestly a much clearer picture than
most of the other mcu titles in the
pipeline
that exposes marvel's secret plan to
interconnect
the various mcu phase 4 titles i'm gonna
break down what we have learned and
spoiler warning if you prefer to stay in
the dark i get it sometimes this hot gas
is just a little too hot from hot voss
so hot right now now to be clear kamala
khan has been associated with the
avengers and teams like the champions
and the new avengers but
the young avengers lineup consists of
iron lad
hulkling patriot wiccan hawkeye kate
bishop stature
a new version of vision and speed later
versions added kid loki
miss america aka america chavez marvel
boy and prodigy now in addition to
wiccan speed stature and kate bishop
these mcu titles could also be setting
up america chabez with
zochi gomez recently cast in an
unconfirmed role in doctor strange and
multiverse of madness whom many of us
believe could be the star kicking
multiverse hopper america chavez now
iron lad could come about a few
different ways
jonathan magers was cast as kang the
conqueror we think who is technically
nathaniel richards iron lad from the
distant future
no others are hoping the return of
harley keener at tony's funeral and
avengers endgame
could mean he could follow in tony
stark's footsteps as an iron lad tight
figure
but kamala khan miss marvel has a
different backstory she's a relatively
recent addition to the marvel comics
introduced in the captain marvel comic
in 2013 before getting her own run in
2014
kamala is a pakistani american muslim
teenager living in new jersey then she
gets covered by a terrigen
mist and becomes an inhuman she cocoons
up and inside that cocoon she sees a
vision
of her heroes carol danvers captain
america iron man
giving kamala the chance to take
whatever form she wants and she emerges
from that cocoon and the appearance of
carol danvers saves a couple lives but
it doesn't last long
really she just has the power to
shape-shift to stretch her body
embigging her limbs she ends up
following in the footsteps of carol
danvers captain marvel and kamala takes
on the name
of miss marvel you might know her from
marvel's avengers game
she's such a cool character who teaches
us a lot about the interesting cultural
life of growing up as a muslim american
in new jersey she dreams of being able
to eat bacon and cheeseburgers but her
parents don't let her eat that she's
just really great but one of the updates
i was most interested to hear about her
was the report that before kamala
appears in her own solo series on disney
plots
she's going to first be introduced in
another mystery mcu title
now captain marvel 2 seems like the
obvious one right but that won't come
until
july 2022 and miss marvel series is
expected to release before that so that
tells us she's probably gonna team up
with one of these other
mcu heroes coming sooner and based on
some interesting clues
i have a pretty strong suspicion that
she is first going to appear
in the falcon the winter soldier but
before we continue thank you to
grammarly for sponsoring this video
grammarly is a digital writing assistant
that helps
more than 20 million people write more
clearly and effectively every day
grammarly premium helps you look
professional by keeping your writing
concise and effective
the job market is tough right now and if
you're hustling on linkedin or emailing
potential employers you really can't
afford spelling mistakes or grammar
mistakes other written mistakes so
grammarly is super easy to install in
your browser from the link in the
description
and they offer a free version that
reviews critical spelling and grammar
mistakes but i find grammarly
premiums clarity ai super helpful a blue
underline shows up on my emails and
documents when i'm being overly wordy or
redundant it just helps me point out the
words i don't need and get to the point
and i'm telling you this helps me in
everything i'm using like when i'm on
gmail and i'm drafting up an email to a
co-worker or a family member
grammarly just nicely drops in here to
say hey maybe you could say things this
way hey maybe
he's a bullet your co-workers will be
less confused by what you're trying to
say and your family members might love
you more grammarly premium also has
vocabulary suggestions that help you
replace
boring or bland words with better
options and formatting suggestions for
things like bulleted lists that make it
easy for your reader to understand your
core message just go to grammarly.com
newrockstars to sign up for a free
account and get 20
off grammarly premium today again that's
grammarly.com
newrockstars okay okay so around the
time iman valani was officially cast as
marvel's kamala khan
another actress who claimed to have
auditioned for this world decided to
prove it
by releasing what she said was the
script pages she read in her audition
as well as the non-disclosure agreement
she signed promising to keep all this a
secret
maybe not the smartest move against the
disney galactic empire which i assume is
why you can no longer find her account
now in the industry these script pages
are just called sides they're really
just written up for casting purposes
with
placeholder dialogue different names
most of the time
never in the final shooting script in
this form or at least heavily heavily
rewritten
so yes take these pages with a huge
grain of salt but still they might give
us a general thematic scope of the kind
of relationships and themes kamala khan
and marvel's next class of avengers will
be dealing with like for example i find
it interesting that
hana i assume the placeholder name used
for kamala cites
the falcon and the winter soldier as her
go-to avengers now yes initially the
dialogue is covered but later on the
jake character mistakenly calls them
the eagle in the winter soldier so i
assume falcon was the other bird there
but she calls
both of them superheroes suggesting to
me that we might not be talking to
kamala khan's sidekick character from
the comics bruno who admittedly does
have pretty good hair
but rather another young hero with a bit
of
an inferiority complex it's also
interesting that the jake character
makes a delicious flatbread yet admits
that he doesn't relate with her struggle
to balance with the multiple cultural
identities that she feels are thrust
upon her presumably jake must feel
pretty assimilated
but he's out of the loop enough to have
no idea who the falcon winter soldier
are
one of the other young avengers we have
talked about being established in these
upcoming mcu phase 4 titles could be
patriot eli bradley the grandson of
isaiah bradley
the black captain america who was erased
from history actor carl lumley was cast
in a mystery role in the falcon winter
soldier that many of us has speculated
could be
isaiah bradley a kind of thematic
reflection to sam wilson about how their
government
doesn't want them to be the
shield-bearing hero in the young
avengers comics eli bradley reveals that
he never
actually got a blood transfusion from
his grandfather to make him super strong
he was actually juicing on the mutant
growth hormone but
after getting off the drug he still
stays on the team in a leadership role
that could explain
this character situation here a kid
familiar with the cap legend but not so
much the lesser known avengers
himself a non-super superhero and maybe
it's nothing but you know that kind of
flatbread while known for the indian
subcontinent cuisine is also a big part
of jamaican dishes and lots of caribbean
food i'm just saying it's very possible
that the falcon winter soldier
introduces
a young eli bradley as a future
successor to
the shield a kid who just so happens to
be friends with an avengers stan
named kamala from jersey city it's just
that the timing seems a bit
convenient right kamala khan announced
right as the falcon winter soldier was
in the middle of reshoots
and right as it was reported that kamala
would first come out in another mcu
title
while other young avengers get
established throughout this universe i
think
kamala and eli could lead the assembly
of those new avengers discuss these
nerdy theories with me on new rockstar's
official discord server but becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
here on youtube hit that notification
bell follow me on instagram at eavos
follow new rockstars thank you for
watching and remember
vote
[Music]
you
[Music]